[Music]
John and I we absolutely love each other
and we care about each other a lot we
are best friends and right now we're
both giving each other time separately
and maybe there's hope that we reunite
in the future time it's gonna take time
Nikki Bella still admitting there's hope
for a reconciliation with ex John Cena
and reacting to what he said on a Today
Show earlier this week don't want
anybody else he loves Nicole I don't
have any other hopes other than maybe
one day that we can work it out I think
I was like the rest of the world I was
speechless at first and then I felt
emotional and I'm very happy he has a
really big heart and he wears it on his
sleeve and I do as well
but that what he did takes courage
especially I think for a man and so I
love John and I love Nicole and you know
he'll always be a brother to me and you
know time like she said time will tell
well time will tell if the pair gets
back together season three of their show
total Bella's will show viewers what led
to the Flint you are gonna completely
see it unfold you're gonna get a sea
wedding planning which is awesome but
you'll see the ups and downs with that
and then you will see what got us to
where we're at today I'm not sure we
should the hardest part about reality TV
is reliving the Downs in your life but
then you also get a really relive these
amazing ups I that's you know it
definitely is hard to relive